now the wearing of masks is set to be a
personal choice
from july the 19th but some pubs
restaurants and shops say they will
still encourage customers to wear them
meanwhile the mayor of greater
manchester andy burnham has said it is
reckless to lift this requirement to
wear masks on public
transport well i'm pleased to say that
andy burnham joins us now
from lee mr burnham good afternoon to
you
good afternoon and boris johnson in
prime minister's questions earlier on
today
refuted the accusation that his plans
were reckless and he gave his reasons
behind that
what did you make of it because you have
yourself called his plans reckless
well i should start by saying i broadly
support the road map and the
approach the government is taking but i
do think they've gone a step too
far with the removal of the requirement
to wear masks particularly on public
transport
there is a question there about whether
they should be required an essential
retail
as well and that's because this isn't a
matter of individual
freedom as as it's been said around
freedom day
one person's freedom is another person's
loss of freedom because if
you're somebody who um has um
a compromised immune system or somebody
who's traveling by
public transport for their chemotherapy
you know they will be put in a very
different difficult position
and i don't think it's too much to ask
at this stage knowing that people
don't like wearing masks but
nevertheless this is about still looking
after everybody as we go through
the later stages of this of this
pandemic and i think the government went
too far
in removing the requirement to wear
masks and i know that
your freedom day for some will be loss
of freedom date for others
so what would you like to see stay you
mentioned the wearing of masks on public
transport
and in essential retail for example so
i'm presuming you mean things like
chemists and supermarkets is there
anything else you would like to see
stay for the foreseeable future
well that is the main thing and i think
the difference is
places that people go by choice so if
people are going to go to bars
restaurants or even nightclubs
come the 19th of july that is a choice
and you know where you're
going into and you're aware of the risks
there are many people in greater
manchester who have no choice
but to use public transport or to go
into the
shops that you you mentioned essential
retail
and i think that's a very different
thing when people are in that
environment
and i think it's unfair that some people
may feel now very uncomfortable in that
environment or worse not even able to to
go in there
and and use those facilities so i think
that is where the government has got
things
wrong more broadly as i say i
can see a lot of logic in what they are
doing and of course we do have to
to learn to live with the virus and and
return as much as we can to normal life
the risk though of course is
if you remove all the restrictions and
the requirements
it kind of suggests or it sends a
message that we're back to normal that
we're out of the pandemic and of course
that isn't the case and i i do have a
concern
that later in the year the government
will have to backtrack in some way if
if um if we see and rising cases or a
new variant or
or some other change in the way things
are are
evolving mr berlin perhaps you can
remind us what the situation is in
greater manchester at the moment i
understand infection numbers are going
up but
at a slower rate than the national
average
yes i mean infection rates are going up
in
in each of our 10 boroughs um and the
the rate of increase has slowed as you
as you say but
they're still high there's no getting
away from that
and that is why you know we are in a
different position
and it's why i do have some concerns
about what's been been announced but as
elsewhere
the link between hospitalization is
is um broken to a some considerable
degree not
completely because there are still
people in hospital and those numbers
have have increased but it's not
the same as we saw uh in 2020 or
or indeed early 2021 so you know it's it
it's a difficult thing i think when you
have the government saying we could be
up to a hundred thousand cases a day in
a
few weeks time as the health secretary
said this week oh and by the way we're
removing all restrictions
i think that the kind of contradiction
there has caused some uncertainty
and some unease amongst our residents
and i do think when the prime minister
goes to the liaison committee today i do
think he needs to be asked
about this uh and to to give the
evidence as to why this is a
uh a step that we're able to take at
this stage yeah
nice of you to mention that that promo
is our 3 30 taking of that live here on
sky news you can watch it plenty of
questions for the prime minister to
answer
i want to talk about education because
obviously there's the july 19th date but
there's also been this date of august
the 16th put in people's diary
self-isolation is going to continue up
until that date and that has a big
impact
on young people and schools
what are your thoughts on the
self-isolation restrictions and when
they're being lifted and what are you
thinking about school bubbles coming to
an end do you support the measures that
are going to have an effect on education
i certainly know that there's been a bit
of an intake of breath around the organ
states
for the end of self-isolation and you
know that definitely feels too
too soon here uh given that
as i've just said the health secretary
is predicting cases at 100 000
um a day later later this month or into
next month so that seems again an
odd decision i would be saying to the
government they should be going the
opposite
way giving more support for people to
self-isolate who need
to do so there is a different situation
in schools where
much of the um of the cases is
related to people with no illness so
that people
who are asymptomatic and the situation
in schools have become unsustainable
so i do think the education secretary
was right to
announce the changes that he that he has
um
i mean it's a period of uncharted
territory that we're going into no one
quite knows now
how things are going to unfold over over
the coming
weeks and i think we still have to er on
the side of
of caution and hence my kind of concern
at some of what's what's been announced
uh but i do think the position in
schools have definitely become
unsustainable
and i know it's been broadly welcomed
the changes that the health sec the
education secretary has announced
how frustrating is it for you to be
mayor of greater manchester at the
moment because
obviously we're talking about powers
going to regions so you can make your
own decisions but
in an instance like this the prime
minister is almost saying to you
you know make up your own mind make up
your own decisions but you have
no authority if you see what i mean in
terms of
if you want to enforce mass on public
transport in greater manchester
or in shops you can't really you can
only advise people so what are you
saying to the people of greater
manchester today
ahead of these two key dates it it is
difficult
uh sergey and i i do think you're right
to point to that because
when a statement is made by the
government it's hard for us to take a
different position
um particularly given here we only
control the tram system
so we can only if we wanted to we can
only enforce masks there we can't
enforce them on buses
or trains because of the way transport
is organized outside of london i think
there's more ability to enforce in
london
than we have so that makes it very hard
because obviously it's a recipe for
confusion or tension
if we try to do that and it is a bit
frustrating again that there was no
genuine consultation with us about this
this change
given that we have to deal with the
consequences on on public transport of
this
of this uh change so um
i have kind of been in a position all
through the pandemic where
governments have imposed things on us
without talking to us we have that from
the scottish government recently where
they introduced a travel ban
which we succeeded in in having
overturned but you know i do think this
says something about how this country is
governed i think we do need to see more
consultation
with people at a a regional level
so that we can help the government make
sense of its obligations or it's
its instructions on on the ground and 18
months into this pandemic we're still in
a position where we sometimes find
what's said quite frustrating
yeah i know that you and the other um
regional mayors were not consulted at
all on the prime minister's plans that
he announced you found out
like the rest of us um just i'm gonna go
to our political editor beth rigby uh
shortly because we are looking ahead to
this
uh liaison committee where boris johnson
is going to face more questions
what would you like to see him answer
today what's your burning question for
the prime minister
i think the burning question is
reassuring people that it is
safe um to do what what has been
announced
given where cases are but i think he
also needs to give mps
a sense of the backup plan what what if
it doesn't go in the way that we
we hope it will go uh because i do think
that that can't be an
unanswered question this can't be
irreversible as he said because it may
we may not be in a position
to do that i would also like to see him
address other issues
like um the support for young people
coming out of this
uh pandemic i was disappointed recently
when i saw the government
you know completely ignore the
recommendations of sir kevin collins
because i think
the next generation is going to need a
lot of support
to recover from this i was pleased to
hear the education secretary say
yesterday that
the government was supporting
face-to-face teaching in our
universities
come the autumn and the new new academic
turn but
that says to me that the government
should recognize that young people
haven't had that over the last year in
universities
and they spent over 9 000 pounds in
tuition fees for not having what they
should have which is face-to-face
learning
and i want to see the government
prioritizing young people and making
reparation to young people coming out of
this pandemic and i would say to them
they should give all young people who've
paid full tuition fees
the academic year 20 20 21 a 50
rebate on those fees because actually
this younger generation has given so
much i think
uh in terms of life chances and lost
opportunity through this pandemic
and i've not yet heard from the prime
minister or any minister
how they are going to help this younger
generation kind of repair the damage
get their lives back on track coming out
of this pandemic and i hope some mps on
the liaison committee
start to ask him some serious questions
about this
as well as questions about how he is
going to make
leveling up a real thing coming out of
this pandemic and not just a
scheme that benefits some favored places
rather than places that will really need
his support